[Music]
the hypersonic combined test force at
Edwards is gearing up for the first
flight of the x51
a Waverider flight test vehicle in the
spring of 2010 what we are going to do
is we're gonna take the x51 rate wave
rider we're gonna launch that from a
b-52 at 50,000 feet over the Pacific
Ocean and then the vehicle is going to
drop away it's going to be accelerated
by a solid rocket booster up to about
Mach four-and-a-half at which time the
solid rocket booster will drop away and
the vehicle and the engine is being
tested is going to ignite and then
further accelerate that vehicle up to
Mach 6 the engine being tested on the 51
a is a hypersonic scramjet propulsion
system a scramjet is a engine that has
no internal moving parts that it takes
the air in you mix fuel in it and it
automatically burns because of the high
speed high temperature that you get in
flight it it now is able to produce a
thrust teams of testers have put in
years of work leading up to the first
flight of the x51 a fairly complicated
test the altitude is right at the very
top of b-52 capabilities we also have
chase they have to be there as well the
telemetry has to be relayed from Naval
Station Point Mugu we have to have a
control room with about 35 people all
watching the various kilometer II so
there's a lot of teamwork acts but
aspects to this whole project testers
say the purpose behind this program is
to demonstrate the ability to use air
breathing hydro carbon propulsion in the
hypersonic flight regime which is flight
more than five times the speed of sound
what makes that a challenge for us and
why we need to do the research is is
that conventional turbine engines are
basically limited about Mach 2.5 or
two-and-a-half times the speed of sound
and it's really tough from the pressure
and the heat and the aerodynamic loads
on the
engines to get anywhere past about Mach
2.5 the the scramjet on this x51 will be
able to take in air and flight speeds of
over Mach 4 and up to Mach 6 and take
air from the atmosphere burn it and then
use it for thrust and if we get that
capability we'll be able to apply this
technology than many other flight
applications that the Air Force might
use the testing of hypersonic technology
at Edwards is not new there was the x-15
program that first flew in 1959 and
there has been very little other
activity since but today's advancements
in technology are giving testers a new
edge well we've been working on scram
Jets in the United States Air Force for
the past 50 years matter of fact there
was a program back in the 90s called the
National aerospace plane that worked on
scramjet engine technology before but
because of those high pressures and
those high temperatures that I talked
about with scramjet engines the
technology of the materials and the
propulsion and how to handle those high
temperatures was not ready so we have
finally come to the point of doing
propulsion research that we're ready to
go fly a scramjet engine and demonstrate
that it's a very viable propulsion
concept to power aerospace vehicles as
scramjet technology is developed testers
believe that in the near future it could
be used to aid war fighters as a weapons
delivery system further down the road it
is believed it will make space access
easier the far turn application really
is all about space lift and this is the
one that I think in an Air Force
Research Lab were most excited about and
I like to tell people if you think about
the shuttle the shuttle is basically how
we get a lot of our payload up into
space now replenish the space station
and things like that the shuttle has to
carry along all of its oxidizer for the
propulsion concept so it's a pure rocket
system if we could incorporate scramjet
engine technology in our space lift
systems as the the Rockets or the
vehicles that go up through spec through
the atmosphere they can acquire the air
through air breathing engine
through the atmosphere and you wouldn't
have to carry those tanks to carry
occupant oxidizers so therefore it makes
the propulsion
cycles much more efficient and then
instead of carrying oxidizer they could
carry more payload in space teams from
the Air Force flight test center the Air
Force Research Laboratory Boeing the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency NASA Pratt & Whitney Rocketdyne
and the US Navy are working with a
hypersonic combined test force on the
x51
a Waverider test project for mr. Johnny
Armstrong who has worked with
hypersonics and Edwards since the early
1960s the x51
a project is one of the highlights of
his career for me personally this is a
real reward towards the end of a career
where I've worked hypersonics and now
all of a sudden this program is here I'm
able after 32 years since the x-15 last
blew I'm able to go back into a control
room and experience a hypersonic flight
test program Don Waldman Edwards Air
Force Base California